c'était donc le cinquième et dernier
volet de la série c'était la guerre
d'Algérie co écrit par Georges Marc
Benhamou et Benjamin Stora et que nous
avons le plaisir de vous proposer dans
cette émission des Badoc un épisode nous
venons de le voir qui retrace les trois
dernières années de la guerre opposant
la France à l'Algérie avant que cette
dernière ne finisse par obtenir son
indépendance voilà 60 ans et après quel
fut le chemin parcouru par l'Algérie
devenu indépendante et bien nous allons
parler avec historienne malikarahaal
bienvenue à vous malikaral vous êtes
chargés de recherche au CNRS spécialiste
de l'histoire contemporaine de l'Algérie
vous avez dirigé par ailleurs l'Institut
du temps présent et vous êtes l'auteur
entre autres entre autres de ce livre
Algérie
1962 une histoire populaire un ouvrage
publié aux éditions La Découverte 5
juillet 1962 c'est dans l'allégresse et
dans la joie qui est proclamé c'est
dépendance de l'Algérie après 130 ans de
colonisation par la France le premier
président de l'Algérie indépendante sera
ahmed Benbella et qu'on a bien sûr vu à
nombreuses reprises tout au long de ce
conflit et tout au long de ces épisodes
de cette série
quel est le chantier auquel doit
s'atteler Ben Bella au moment de cette
indépendance alors les tâches sont
vraiment nombreuses il faut considérer
un petit peu l'état du pays au sortir de
la guerre et au sortir de la
colonisation la dernière période la
guerre a été extrêmement cruelle ça veut
dire que on a toute une partie de la
population algérienne qui a été
transplantée déplacée de force et
installer dans ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque des camps de regroupement qui
sont des camps de concentration
coloniaux donc un quart de cette
population cherche à rentrer chez elle
quitter ses camps ou réoccuper ces camps
on a des réfugiés à l'extérieur du pays
sont peut-être 300.000 à vivre entre le
Maroc et la Tunisie avec des difficultés
pour entrer dans le pays parce qu'une
partie du territoire et éliminé et ça ne
le voit pas beaucoup d'ailleurs oui
malheureusement ce vécu très algérien
qui laisse aussi peu de traces et peu de
peu de récit mais qu'on peut qu'on peut
identifier n'apparaît n'apparaît pas
alors que vraiment c'est celui de
l'immense majorité du pays et ces gens
qui sont sans logement à la fin de la de
la guerre sans logement souvent sans
travail sont aussi des gens qui vivent
dans un pays dont une grande partie de
la population est en train de partir ce
qu'on appelle du pied noir voilà
contrairement à tout ce qui est imaginé
finalement la grande majorité de ce
million de Français qui vivent en
Algérie quitte le pays extrêmement
brutalement et donc les habitants qui
demeurent vont assez rapidement
réoccuper l'espace préoccuper les
logements préoccuper les villes parce
que les quartiers européens c'est comme
ça qu'on les appelait
surtout les zones rurales oui et puis
dans les villes des quartiers plutôt
restreint on avait des formes de partage
de l'espace voire d'apartheid dans
certaines villes même s'il est pas du
tout aussi totale que l'expression peut
le laisser le laisser penser mais il y a
une réoccupation très rapide et
spontanée sous la force du besoin de ces
de ces logements avec des gens qui
s'installent dans des logements ou
demeurent des meubles ou demeurent des
photographies ou demeure parfois des
livres ou d'autres ou d'autres biens
avec lesquels parfois ils vont continuer
à vivre et parmi les grands chantiers
également on a celui évidemment de la
construction d'un état c'est la
naissance d'un état dans sa version
moderne la possibilité de créer des
administrations avec des urgences
immédiates faire fonctionner les
hôpitaux soigner organiser une santé
publique lancer la rentrée scolaire avec
le départ des pieds-noirs qui étaient
très nombreux notamment dans l'éducation
on se retrouve avec une difficulté déjà
à faire fonctionner le système éducatif
tel qu'il était mais en plus la grande
promesse de l'Algérie indépendante c'est
de pouvoir vraiment soigner éduquer
l'ensemble de sa population et donc il y
a une urgence immédiate à organiser la
rentrée faire tourner les écoles faire
tourner les lycées la scolarisation sera
d'ailleurs un défi important des filles
d'une certaine manière avait raté
la France durant cette période de
colonisation l'assimilation par la
scolarisation est un échec seulement 10%
de la population
musulmane était scolarisée durant la
période coloniale française oui on
lisait souvent que le coin de la
scolarisation de l'ensemble de la
population aurait été beaucoup trop
élevé c'est un défi effectivement que
relève l'Algérie indépendante dans les
10 ou 15 années qui suivent
l'indépendance et la possibilité de
scolariser très largement d'alphabétiser
ces plus jeunes et de proposer du coup
un état qui a une toute autre échelle
c'est-à-dire pas un état désormais
principalement pour la population
coloniale mais un état qui se veut et
c'est bien difficile à réaliser un état
qui nourrit tout le monde qui soigne et
qui éduquent l'ensemble de sa de sa
population ça ça va être vraiment les
très grandes défis des premières années
de l'indépendance amen Bella on restera
président de l'Algérie pendant trois ans
il y aura un putsch il y aura une
véritable lutte de pouvoir qui se
poursuivra parce qu'on pressend à la fin
de cet épisode qu'il y a déjà des enjeux
de pouvoir très fort à l'intérieur de
des nationalistes et des
indépendantistes De de l'époque et c'est
wariboumédiène qui va entamer son air de
pouvoir pendant plusieurs années entre
1965 et 1978 est-ce qu'on peut dire
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une
révolution socialiste est-ce que on a à
faire un pouvoir socialiste avec
ce que sont les les méthodes socialistes
de l'époque sachant que notamment
l'Union soviétique était le premier
partenaire à la fois économique et
militaire du pouvoir algérien naissant
on peut parler d'une politique
socialiste planification nationalisation
répartition des terres agraires telles
que vous l'avez défini tout à l'heure
c'est ça les la grande ligne politique
de
l'indépendance algérienne dans ses
premières années alors cette inspiration
socialiste on la sent déjà pendant la
guerre ce qu'il faut se représenter
c'est à quel point le déroulement de ce
qui se passe au moment de l'indépendance
favorise en réalité cette ligne
socialiste le fait par exemple d'avoir
des logements laissés vacances d'avoir
des terres agricoles coloniales laissées
vacantes finalement ça donne un rôle
considérable à l'état qui va
nationaliser des terres et nationaliser
des biens l'État va devenir par exemple
le premier propriétaire de bien locatif
donc ça lui donne une force de frappe en
termes de d'État socialiste d'État
bienveillants qui peut se préoccuper de
politique de logement de même que ça va
lui donner une force de frappe dans le
domaine de l'agriculture qui est inouï
il y a des théoriciens de l'époque qui
viennent observer ce qui se passe en
Algérie et qui disent en fait presque
sans coup fait rire l'État algérien se
retrouve à la tête on dit à l'époque un
million d'hectares se trouve à la tête
d'un million d'hectares ça lui donne la
possibilité de faire une révolution
agraire que d'autres États ne feraient
qu'au prix de
d'accaparement de terre ou de ou de
séquestre de terre qui qui serait très
impopulaire là ça met l'État algérien
dans une position
particulièrement avancée dans le domaine
de la de la révolution de la révolution
socialiste et ça lui permet d'avoir une
politique très interventionniste
effectivement et dans le domaine
agricole et dans le domaine de du
logement politique pas de pluralisme
politique il arrivera plus tard on en
parlera tout à l'heure on a un parti
unique des taux de colos qui n'est autre
que le Front de libération nationale
avec de grands débats dès 1962 alors
paradoxalement quand on replonge dans
les débats de l'époque c'est assez
intéressant de voir que même des gens
qui plus tard seront démocrates et
souhaiteront ouvrir le jeu politique se
pose à l'époque la question de savoir si
le pluralisme est une bonne chose ou si
au contraire le FLN peut être comme dans
d'autres pays un front dans lequel il y
aurait des courants distincts parce
qu'au fond même si nous divergeons les
uns des autres nous sommes tous des
révolutionnaires donc on a ce type de
débat et puis le pays devient
indépendant après 132 ans de
colonisation et donc il y a des
questions très profondes de savoir
qu'est-ce que l'algérialité comment se
définit-on quel est notre langue quelle
est notre culture quelle est notre
identité notre identité collective donc
à côté de mesures qui est très
socialisante voilà quelle place doit
pouvoir la religion qui était déjà une
question à l'époque coloniale qui était
un peu le refuge identitaire sous la
domination coloniale comment garder au
centre en quelque sorte là là la
religion comme une part importante de de
l'identité certains tout de même
qualifient ces terres de Warri
Boumédiène de dictature militaire
certains vont jusque là pour décrire ce
qui a été cette période Boumédiène on a
effectivement une forte répression on a
parfois des opposants qui par moments
sont arrêtés sont torturés et dans le
même temps se passe en Algérie ce qui se
passe à la même époque en Égypte de gens
qui parfois depuis leur prison envoient
des lettres de soutien à certains
aspects de la politique bomédianiste
donc on est dans une dans un panorama
politique qui est extrêmement complexe
de gens qui sont réprimés parce que il
n'appartiennent pas au Front de
libération nationale mais qui de l'autre
côté soutient la politique par exemple
de nationalisation du pétrole et du gaz
en 1971 où la politique tiers mondiste
la politique panafricaniste la politique
panarabiste de boomédiène d'ailleurs il
y aura un courant non aligné qui naîtra
à la fin de des années durant ces années
60 dans quel participera cette nouvelle
Algérie je sais pas si on peut l'appeler
comme ça ensuite Chadli boudjedid va
prendre le pouvoir pendant plusieurs
années lui aussi il tente de libéraliser
un petit peu le pays oui c'est une on
est on est au tournant des années 1980
le monde change il y a la Révolution
iranienne on est on est plus éloigné de
l'enthousiasme révolutionnaire et de
l'enthousiasme des indépendances et on a
une une tension une tendance vers des
formes de libéralisation de
déstructuration des entreprises étatique
notamment et une poussée autour des
questions de l'autonomie politique des
questions aussi de genre de droit des
femmes des questions aussi de culture
régionale de notamment la question de la
place de la culture berbère en Algérie
avec une ébullition qui apparaît de
façon très nette à la fin des années
1980 depuis 1980 des années 80 qui se
finissent avec une très forte répression
dans 1988 500 morts tout de même suite à
une répression suite à des
manifestations contre ce président il
quittera d'ailleurs le pouvoir peu en
peu de temps après
et il fera une concession c'est le plus
rameisme politique en 89 ça c'est un
tournant tout de même dans la vie
politique du pays c'est un tournant
extrêmement important et c'est un
tournant dont on se souvient aujourd'hui
souvent en le comparant avec ce qui
s'est passé à partir de 2019 et le
mouvement populaire c'est une phase qui
démarre avec une série de manifestations
et d'émeutes notamment de la jeunesse
qui s'exprime en Algérie comme elle
s'exprime aussi dans d'autres pays au
Maghreb ou hommage REC à la même à la
même époque effectivement une
transformation une transition politique
avec soit la légalisation de partie qui
avait été clandestin pendant les années
précédentes soit de fondation de partie
nouveau alors la légalisation de partie
clandestin ça va être par exemple
l'héritier du Parti communiste qui
s'avère finalement peut-être être moins
puissant qu'on ne l'avait imaginé en
cette fin d'année 1980 dans un contexte
de crise du communisme international et
création de partie nouveau ça va être
par exemple la création du Front
islamique du du salut qui aura ensuite
une un héritage important c'est
l'émergence du Fils vous voulez le citer
qui remporte d'abord les élections
locales ensuite le premier tour de
détection législative c'est à toute fin
de l'année 1991 et la nuit est l'armée
va annuler cette élection et on rentre
là dans une période très sombre de du
pays que l'Algérie 10 années de guerre
civiles ça c'est une marque importante
tout de même une marque sombre dans
l'histoire et c'est une c'est une un
moment dont il est difficile et
important de de de faire l'histoire et
notamment de contextualiser ce moment de
la fin des années 80 et du début des
années 90 il faut se rappeler on n'est
pas du tout dans le monde maghrébin et
du Machrek de des années 2000 ou des
années 2010 on est beaucoup plus proche
de la révolution de la révolution
iranienne on est aussi dans un contexte
de grève insurrectionnel organisé par le
Front islamique du salut on est devant
une très grande incertitude politique
effectivement l'armée reprend la main
avec des débats qui ont des conséquences
encore aujourd'hui c'est à dire que les
acteurs les plus âgés d'aujourd'hui se
souviennent encore très bien de qui
était en faveur d'une intervention
militaire qui était contre qui était en
faveur de laisser le fils prendre le
pouvoir et faire sa propre expérience
qui était contre ces débats continuent
on n'imagine pas leur présence encore
aujourd'hui dans la vie politique al
Abdelaziz Bouteflika c'est lui qui
mettra un terme avec un concordat à
cette fameuse
guerre civile qui aura duré 10 ans il va
régner assez longtemps lui aussi
jusqu'en 2019
avec un nouveau mouvement de
contestation encore une fois les jeunes
et Dieu sait si cette population est
jeune la moyenne d'âge aujourd'hui en
Algérie de 29 ans
encore une contestation et toujours un
peu pour les mêmes motifs on veut
abattre un système le fameux système
algérien dont on sait pas très bien nous
parfois de ce côté de la Méditerranée de
quoi on parle exactement
en tout cas de mettre à bas ce fameux
système qui fait que beaucoup
s'accaparent les richesses du pays au
détriment peut-être du peuple alors ce
qui est très clair dans le début du
mouvement et ce qui fait absolument
l'unanimité spectaculaire on se rappelle
un de ces images du Irak de le 19 c'est
vraiment le refus d'un cinquième mandat
d'un président fatigué affaibli
incapable de parler incapable de marcher
incapable de du coup parler au nom du
pays et un problème les manifestants ont
gain de cause et surtout l'impression
que c'est manifestations réparent
quelque chose qui qui faisait souffrir
le pays depuis les années 1990 la
population refait unité dans une forme
d'enthousiasme et d'une forme de joie
collective et partagée certains des plus
anciens se rappelleront des
manifestations de 1962 des festivités de
62 en disant c'est le même type de
manifestation d'existence vraiment les
premières semaines de ce Irak sont un
moment de réparation du corps du corps
collectif de fait les réformes
politiques sont restreintes la grande
victoire c'est la non représentation de
de Bouteflika et
un peu différent peut-être moins
unanimiste moins populaire que n’était
les premières semaines mais avec une
équipe toujours
à l'issue final incertaine ni à l'heure
actuelle la lecture de ce qui est le
pouvoir algérien ni la lecture de ce
qu'est le helac ne sont ne sont aussi
clair que dans ces premières semaines
mais on est toujours dans une séquence
historique qui est ouverte et qui ne
s'est pas refermée ça va être ma
dernière question le FLN aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il a pas perdu de sa superbe
auprès de ce peuple algérien 60 ans
après après la cette fameuse déclaration
de l'indépendance tous les présidents
tous les leaders algériens pendant 60
ans avait fait cette guerre d'Algérie
était parmi ceux qui avaient gagné cette
indépendance est-ce que cet aura est
encore à l'ordre du jour du côté de ses
anciens leaders du FLN et du FLN
lui-même qui reste un parti Dominique un
peu parti politique important encore ça
reste un parti politique important et ça
reste un parti politique qui est
vraiment auréolé de de sa notoriété liée
liée à la garde indépendance à
différents moments on voit bien
apparaître cette revendication de on
devrait en quelque sorte musée ici le
front libération nationale il nous le
FLN de la guerre nous appartient à tous
mais aujourd'hui le champ politique
devrait être devrait être différent même
si je le rappelle 90% de la population
algérienne n'a pas fait cette guerre
exactement et d'un autre côté savoir
aujourd'hui ce qu'il représente demeure
une question moi j'aimerais beaucoup
avoir une enquête pour savoir est-ce que
est-ce que dans les campagnes loin des
villes dans les endroits qu'on va peut
qu'on va qu'on va peut interroger
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il représente je
pense que si on arrivait à répondre à
cette question on aurait peut-être une
vision un peu plus claire de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui notamment la jeunesse
algérienne et à quel point se souvenir
lui parle ou pas dans le présent
merci beaucoup
malikaral d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
débat doc et ce dernier épisode de notre
série c'était la guerre d'Algérie vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag débadoc
bien entendu sur Twitter merci à sel
massali qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission tout au long de cette semaine
autour de cette série cossignée par
Benjamin Stora et Georges Marc Benhamou
je vous donne bien sûr rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]